it's seven o'clock which means you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster fresh concern over
viral variants more
mass testing announced and the toughest
restrictions yet
at our borders plenty to talk about with
the transport secretary grant shafts on
the show
momentarily but also this morning
a lost generation of swimmers we're
going to be joined by the olympic gold
medalist duncan goody
who's worried about the effects of the
pandemic on our children
learning to swim also coming up
[Music]
scandalous we're going to be joined by
the mystique singer sabrina washington
to talk about the new campaign
to smash the barriers facing black
musicians
it is wednesday the 10th of february
my name is elton john bit more showbiz
my name is elton john i've just had a
vaccine
for kobe it didn't hurt
celebrities appeared in the new nhs
vaccine video
as more mass testing is announced for
south london following fresh cases of a
variant
holiday hope from the travel industry
after the toughest measures yet are
announced for our borders
mass tourism really does normally start
then
hopefully we'll be in a position where
we can travel
cladding crisis the government is
expected to announce billions of pounds
to help homeowners
the former president donald trump to
face a second impeachment trial
after the senate voted to reject
republican arguments that it would be
unconstitutional
parkinson's breakthrough now scientists
have taken a vital step forward
in their quest to find a cure
i'm here live that's not i'm not a cat
i can i can see that
it's a catastrophe we'll be getting to
the bottom of the case of a lawyer whose
zoom filter made him just look like a
little kitten in court
and last night we had the coldest night
in 10 years but tonight
is set to be even colder i'll have all
the details for you
later in the program
uh morning all we begin this morning
with fresh concerns over variance of the
virus new
mass testing announce to get on top of
it and the toughest measures to date
revealed
for our borders uh well surge testing
is to begin in south london after the
first cases of the south african variant
were discovered there
residents in parts of lambeth are being
asked to take a test
whether they have the symptoms or not
meanwhile
scientists advising the government of
classed a mutation of the kent covered
variant
found in bristol as a variant of concern
all this as the government attempts to
stop new variants coming into the uk
by forcing uk and irish residents
returning from 33 redless countries
to pay 1 750 pounds to quarantine in
hotels for 10 days
the measures come in from monday and
anyone not doing so faces fines of as
much as 10 000 pounds
or even 10 years in jail for lying skies
melina vesselin which has the detail
as freezing winds batter britain many
are dreaming of foreign holidays in the
sun
but tough new border restrictions mean
that hopes of going abroad this summer
are diminishing
strict new rules mean that all arrivals
from countries on the red list have to
quarantine in hotels
at a personal cost of a thousand seven
hundred and fifty pounds
everyone else must get a covet test on
day two and eight of isolating
in addition to testing negative before
departure
the clam down has led holiday giant judd
two to cancel all
bookings until mid-april but some in the
travel industry hope
that stringent measures now will allow
for travel to restart by the summer
we're really four months away at least
until mass travel normally starts anyway
all countries around the world are
putting these strict measures in now um
because
when things really do you know when when
mass tourism really does normally start
then hopefully we'll be in a position
where we can travel
scientists though are less optimistic
that sounds completely divorced from
reality at a point in time where
not only are we seeing different
variants being imported from different
parts of the world but we're seeing
evolution of the virus right now within
the uk with new
mutations emerging which are really
concerning and might influence our
vaccine effectiveness
the idea that somehow things will be
normal in terms of travel
travel by summer is completely
unrealistic
as with so many other things in this
pandemic there's no certainty to when
we'll be able to travel again milan
vasilinevich
sky news
i'm very pleased to say that the
transport secretary grant shaps joins us
once again on the program good to see
you this morning mr schaps
a busy few days ahead for you and indeed
for your team
um so let's start with with the borders
uh this morning shall we we heard from
the health secretary
a list of new measures to to toughen up
uh at the borders to the united kingdom
can you just run us through them but but
also
just explain exactly why we are we are
doing this at this point in time
yeah i guess the first things to say is
it's not about the prevalence of the
virus elsewhere now it's about the
variance
and that's the thing that we're tracking
that's why we're taking a slightly
different approach but these are
additional things that we're doing on
top of things like
pre-departure testing that was already
required before you
travel here from somewhere else and a
passenger locator form that you have to
fill in by law and you can be thrown off
the flight if you if you don't have in
fact you won't get onto the flight if
you don't have it
but now in addition to that when you get
back here you must
quarantine again that's been in place
but also
take mandatory tests on day two and day
eight and in addition to that there are
a set of countries we call them the red
list countries
33 of them at the moment where we're
saying there should be
in fact there are no direct flights
whatsoever from those countries that
haven't been for a while again
but if you are traveling via another
route from those countries
then you must quarantine in a hotel and
so that's being introduced as well
uh from monday just in terms of of the
hotel rollout of course clearly there
are
there have been some concerns some
questions about how many rooms we have
available
how many rooms in fact we will need to
maintain the system moving forward
i mean can you can you give us that
detail come monday how many i've got
as of now how many have we got how many
will we have by monday and how many do
we need given you know
people are going to be staying in that
hotel room not for a handful of days but
for
you know a week and a half sure well
first of all there are over five
thousand hotel rooms uh these are sort
of if you like government managed
facilities these hotels the 5000
immediately available
uh and bear in mind these are from
countries where there are no direct
flights at all
a majority of brits will have already
returned from those locations
and very very few people are traveling
at all at this
stage um 16 to 20 000 a day and that
includes the hauliers who
who bring our goods uh to this country
and other categories like um sort of
border workers
so we're down to a very very small
number of people
and we can just increase those numbers
very quickly in a day or so
uh because we've got those agreements in
place can you then just
tell us a little bit more about those
those agreements agreements in place
five five thousand hotel rooms is a
great start clearly but with estimates
you know around about 1500 uh perhaps
visitors arriving from those redless
countries every day
it appears that by you know the middle
of next week we we might be getting
close to capacity
i know i've seen some of those numbers
thrown around and and and i don't think
that
they're correct because um if you think
about the
very small number of people who are
traveling at the moment i mean travel is
95
down on uh where it was this time uh
last year
uh and of the remaining people who
travel once you strip out the lorry
drivers who are bringing our medicines
and foods here
uh frontier workers critical you know
people who come over to for example um
keep our
critical infrastructure uh working um
actually the number of people traveling
uh
overall is very low and then beyond that
we're only talking about another
subsection of people
who are traveling here from those red
list countries uh where there are no
direct flights in any case so we're
talking about a very easy
could you could you put a number then on
it what is the government's estimate
even at the moment that probably comes
to less than a thousand a day and by
next week when people will have to pay
to do this 1750 pounds package
on top of of course their costs of
getting here are an indirect
route i think we'll find the numbers are
actually pretty small but as i say
either way
it's fine because we can increase hotel
numbers very very
quickly we've got those agreements in
place how do we
as a number of colleagues of yours on
conservative benches are asking
how do we get out of this what is the
the the the
the bar that we need to surpass to start
drawing down on these on these travel
restrictions
yeah i mean look i'm transport secretary
so i absolutely
want people to be able to travel but it
is a fact
that right now it's illegal to leave
your home to go on holiday it's illegal
to do that in the uk
or um or around the world so i'm afraid
at the moment that's that's off the
cards
having said that um fortunately i think
the the total number of
vaccinations injected now is 13.1
million overall
uh in this country which i just checked
actually is more than all of the eu put
together
in terms of the number of people being
vaccinated so far so we're
we're getting great guns on that and
we're moving very fast that's a very
very important part of
how we get to unlock the situation and
the prime minister will make
a statement about this and say more
about it on the 22nd
when he'll be able to set out a sort of
route to unlock um
very similar to what happened last year
but of course now this time
not just with the benefit of seeing the
reductions through the lockdown but also
the reductions through
vaccine and i should also say through
the massive testing
program that's now in place that's
enabled us to surge the testing in
certain areas where we've seen these
variants as well
so we've got a lot more sort of tools in
our armory now
i can't give you an exact date at this
stage the prime minister will say more
and then we'll have a
a series of dates during which we will
be able to gradually
unlock things if we see cases continue
to reduce and
and and deaths as well forgive me if
i'm if i'm wrong here but it does feel
that you seem rather more confident
about us getting
some form of summer holiday than than
perhaps even the health secretary i mean
yesterday
it did rather feel that he was linking
as coming out of this
uh significant action on our borders to
you know a booster vaccine
come the autumn that might provide that
additional protection
against the variants that let's not
forget are already in the country
despite the action that we're taking
right now
yeah yeah look and i don't want to kind
of
unnecessarily raise people's hopes the
truth is we just don't know
how the virus will respond and both to
the vaccines and
of course how people will respond and
therefore to the social distancing and
those kind of
measures and therefore exactly when
we'll be able to unlock so i'm afraid i
can't give you a definitive
will there or will there not be the
opportunity to take holidays this next
year either at home or abroad
but what i do know is right now thanks
to
people adhering to the the lockdown and
thanks to the enormous vaccination
program it's just been
extraordinary as i say more more than
the whole of the rest of the you put
together
in terms of injections thanks to those
two things
we are starting to see those reductions
but i don't know what the situation will
be uh by the middle of the
summer uh nobody can tell from the point
that we we
sit right now and so i'm afraid it is
sitting tight observing the rules
uh and waiting for if you haven't had
your injection yet uh depending on the
category you're in waiting for that call
unless you're
over 70 in which case please do contact
uh your gp
or go to nhs uh website administrator if
this toughening up at the borders was as
you say
to do with you know dealing with
variants of the virus
variants which like the south african
virus south african variant
may have you know some form of
resistance to the vaccines that we have
on stream at the moment haven't we
somewhat missed the boat why has it
taken us so long
to get to a point where we are testing
people arriving in this country
after they get into the country so so
first of all it's really important
it's often misunderstood mutations of
the virus take place all the time and
they've been thousands of mutations
of this virus most are uh don't change
um things that they're almost like
passengers within the virus
they come and go throughout this uh
coronavirus there'd be many a time um
where
uh the the level the prevalence the
amount of virus elsewhere
um has been lower uh than it has been
here and in which case
it hasn't really uh much mattered in
fact some some would
say some have argued um that if it's
lower elsewhere
then there's no real concern about
people being outside of the country
simply for the fact that
you have more chance of catching it in
the country if our rates were high
what we're facing now is a different
issue what we're facing now isn't about
the prevalence it's about the variance
and that is essential uh it's essential
that we
don't allow the african variant is
already here my point again was
why is it taking us so long to get to
this it's 12 months since we had the
first
you know death recorded from covid19
plenty of other countries have beaten us
to the punch particularly on
testing not before the border but at or
after the border
why has it taken us so long to catch up
with them the
the number one thing you can do is
quarantine or self-isolate and of course
we've had that in place since
last spring so we we've had that in
place a lot longer than most countries
uh we've actually now got a whole suite
of different things because of these
variants which make it uh
amongst the the toughest in the world
it's up there with the way that south uh
korean countries who um have
traditionally
uh had a much more interventionist
approach to
these sort of uh these sort of issues in
southeast asia where they've tackled
um viruses in the past and these
pandemic
outbreaks but um the reality is
a test as i've explained many times
before is good and interesting but
not as as in terms of tackling the
uh the virus not as good as just
quarantining on its on its own so if you
were going to do one more
why if we all know why if we only
introduced hotel quartering then
that's been going in australia new
zealand since march of last year okay
straightforward question when did the
department for transport
begin working on the policy of hotel
quarantine yeah so hold on let me just
answer your last question and this one
as well
in terms of testing capacity you'll
recall right at the beginning of this
crisis we simply didn't have the
capacity to be
testing everyone in every situation we
started off with less than 2 000 tests a
day
now we've probably got eight or nine
hundred thousand available um
per day so that's a very good reason the
other thing about for example
australia which is an example i always
hear quoted australia is an entire
continent they are
pretty self-sufficient in many different
ways the uk
which for example through the short
straights that connection between
calais and dover imports 75 percent of
its medicines
uh 45 of our food we we can't operate
without those said no one has ever
suggested as far as i'm aware that we
stopped you know holiers bringing
medicines to the united kingdom
what plenty people have suggested is
that perhaps we're a little late to the
late to sorting out you know people
arriving in the united kingdom
from red countries which are now on the
red list i mean it's
it has always been described by the
government the the additional action
which has long been trailed uh the
additional action at our borders was all
about
toughening up an already robust set of
circumstances
yeah but i mean just look at the the way
in which it is being enforced
you know up until this point we've
relied largely on civil penalties
and people doing their duty it is not a
chain it is not a toughening up of that
to say you could
end up in jail for 10 years that's an
entirely new policy
okay so so look first of all um people
have been being checked border forces
have checked 3.7 million
um passenger locator forms as they've
come in
and more recently of course with the
pre-departure testing they've checked
those
as well um so it's not that i can't i
keep hearing people haven't been checked
that that's not
true however you are right to say um
that because the variance is a at a
whole different scale
to just how prevalent the diseases i
mentioned before
there were many times in fact the entire
travel corridor
policy was on the basis that where you
were traveling to had to by definition
have lower levels
of coronavirus than here so that was a
different issue
what we're dealing with now is the
variance and with variance
we cannot risk it in these final stages
where we've got the vaccine role that
rolled out
uh that we might end up with a
difficulty from from variations although
we think so far that we'll be able to
take care of them through
the vaccines and because of that we
think it's appropriate that
things like prison sentences for lying
about being in one of those red list
countries are
appropriate and look i just don't agree
with the idea that we somehow didn't act
quickly i can tell you within six hours
of finding out of one of these variants
this is the mink variant
in denmark we changed the law possibly a
record
time for changing the law in this
country so there'd be many occasions
where we've had to act extremely well i
mean we could mention you know the
kind of the count variant when it hit
london and people have been telling you
to kind of act on that you know a
fortnight before you did
but i i do want to conclude sorry let me
just let me just pick you up on that
because
because that's how these stories get out
there are wrong the variants occur and
we may get a clue about them but as i
said
we see a lot of different mutations
taken
thousands of mutations what you have to
then do is genome sequence them
and that is a
and the process decided not to do it for
a fortnight that was the point though no
no no no no
i do i do want to conclude ministering
correct
fair enough i do want to conclude
minister um there's going to be five
billion pounds worth
of grants and loans today to get rid of
cladding on on buildings and of course
you you have a good degree of experience
of working in housing
stephen mcpartland your colleague says
because you know a building's under 18
meters
people will be having to take out loans
he describes it
uh millions of leaseholders are facing
financial ruin and will not accept loans
they are not a solution
they are a disgraceful betrayal i just
just wonder your thoughts on that
well first of all i mean uh this
cladding situation
has been you know we've all seen the the
impact of it and it's been absolutely
horrendous
the government's already uh put in 1.6
billion
pounds to trying to get the cladding
removed i know that the
uh housing secretary of state will be
saying more this lunch time and he's
got a statement in the house and we'll
have to wait for uh for that
um but there's a a fairly complicated
picture because you have
leaseholders uh but you also have um
sort of joint ownerships uh you
sometimes have council ownerships and i
know that uh robert generic the housing
secretary wants to get to the bottom of
trying to help everybody uh so that
people are not out of pocket i'm
probably we'll have to wait till later
to see exactly what he says and how much
money is involved but i think it's a
good thing the government is standing
behind
people in that position grant shapes
great to see you this morning thanks for
being with me you're welcome
uh let's dwell on that uh with our
political correspondent kate mccann
morning kate um
i i suppose on the speed with which
action has been taken at borders you
know
mr schapps is well well entitled to
maintain that they have done everything
as
quickly as they could it does feel still
though that there is something of a lag
factor when you look at other countries
in the world and not just australia and
new zealand when it comes to
action at the borders yeah and i think
there's going to be some criticism
ongoing towards the government's policy
from the labour party but i think what's
essential now is to see
how it works in practice to see from
monday
you know how many people because you did
push grant chaps on that you suggested 1
500 people a day from those redless
countries he said under a thousand
there's not very much room in that if
you've got five
thousand beds five thousand rooms and
you're asking people to stay for
potentially two weeks if they test
positive
then you're going to start running out
quite quickly he said you could get more
rooms in more hotels but
the question is how will the government
manage that how will they manage the
flow of that
and then again when it comes to opening
up you know how do you go about opening
up easing these restrictions when's the
right time how do you possibly know
given we're talking about variants and
mutations you know when those things are
going to stop but when they might be
less damaging to the uk population
i think the answer to that question is
that nobody ever will so it's going to
be a political choice which again
puts the government in the position it's
in with lockdown of having to make a
very difficult call 13.1 million people
vaccinated though i think that's a new
figure a new figure from
over the last couple of days there's
quite a lot of progress being made
towards that target
and just very quickly on cladding
there's going to be a huge round today
in the conservative party and beyond
that about what happens we really need
to see what robert generic does announce
particularly for those leaseholders that
you mentioned
yep we will have much more from you
throughout the morning kate thanks very
much indeed
at meantime though the nhs has recruited
uh two
major celebrities to promote the
coronavirus vaccination
program my name is elton john
bit more showbiz my name is elton john
i've just had a vaccine for kovid
it didn't hurt
uh well as you can see so michael and
sir elton john both pretending to be
stars
auditioning for a vaccine advertising
campaign
uh so far 13.1 million first dozens have
been administered in the uk people in
society that get vaccinated
and you can watch the second in our
series of special programs
covered corporate crisis learning the
lessons
examining how the uk handled the
coronavirus pandemic sophie region
charge that's at eight o'clock tonight
but so to come on this program we'll be
asking the shadow home secretary nick
thomas simmons
whether labour supports these tough new
penalties for travellers
who fail to obey government restrictions
that's at twenty to eight
the boss of thomas cook is with us at
five past days as the travel industry
faces a second difficult year of
pandemic and at quarter to ten this
morning the former olympic swimmer
duncan goku
is here he's behind a scheme to help
children who've missed out on
swimming lessons during long time
british scientists trying to understand
the causes of parkinson's disease
have made a breakthrough and have taken
a vital step forward in their work to
find a cure
skies alva bennett reports i saw
the worst of the condition take away the
best of my dad
and that was very difficult emotionally
to deal with
anne-marie saw the devastating impact of
parkinson's disease up close
on her father he died in 2013 an
experience that made her diagnosis
just two years later all the more
terrifying
at the moment there is no cure um it's a
one-way street
and that you don't really want to go
down but
you you know that the the support is
there to help you manage your condition
but thanks to research done here at the
university of cambridge there may soon
be more than just support on offer
scientists believe they've finally found
the key to potentially
unlocking a cure it lies in a protein
called alpha cynuclein
shown here as red blobs it causes
parkinson's when it behaves
abnormally and kills healthy brain cells
the mystery has been how it behaves
normally a mystery that
is until now scientists here have been
studying this protein
for more than 20 years trying to figure
out how it functions
in a healthy brain now they finally know
that
they are a vital step closer to not just
understanding
the origins of parkinson's but crucially
how to cure it in order to intervene
and correcting its behavior we first
need to know what it does normally so we
can
when we correct the behavior we don't
interfere with the normal behavior
the musician aussie osborne is among
more than 10 million people living with
parkinson's disease
the fastest growing neurological
condition in the world
the actor michael j fox was diagnosed
age 29
it affects the body's ability to move
and can leave some
unable to walk and talk it's important
that we keep funding this fundamental
research
into you know really getting down to the
nitty-gritty about what causes
parkinson's so that we can then
design effective treatments to actually
slow parkinson's for the first time
for anne-marie even the simplest of
things can be a challenge because of the
tremors she now has
but it's hope this breakthrough may mean
in the future her condition gets better
instead of worse iva bennett sky news
cambridge
eight british men are facing extradition
to the united states after they were
accused of
cyber attacks on the phones of u.s
celebrities
the national crime agency says the men
were arrested in england and scotland
following a joint operation with the fbi
and the u.s
secret service
a 100 year old man in germany has been
charged with being an accessory to more
than three and a half thousand murders
during the second world war the unnamed
man who's been ruled as fit to stand
trial
is accused of working as a guard at a
nazi concentration camp
a woman is in a critical condition after
being shot during a protest in myanmar
yesterday
it's not clear who shot her doctors say
she is
critically ill in hospital
mps say care home staff were without
personal protective equipment during the
first months of the pandemic
because the government prioritized the
nhs the commons public accounts
committee
said the problem was only taken
seriously when death rates
started to increase
rescuers are continuing to search for
165 people still missing
after a glacier collapsed causing a huge
river of mud in
india efforts are being focused on a
tunnel where more than three dozen
workers from a power plant
are thought to be trapped
now in the world of lockdown zoom calls
have become
something of a way of life but still not
everyone gets it right all of the time
one call has gone viral
after a lawyer attending a virtual
hearing in front of a judge
accidentally appeared as a cat mr ponton
i believe
you have a filter turned on in the
video settings you might want to uh
we're trying to can you hear me judge
i can hear you i think it's a filter i'm
here live that's not
i'm not a cat i can i can see that
i'm not a cat brilliant skye's crazy cat
lady becky cotterell
joins us from the newsroom this morning
and becky explained exactly what on
earth was going on there
god knows um this video is so good and
it's exactly the kind of content that we
all need right now to cheer us up
in this cold lockdown the video was
shared on twitter and it's been viewed
over 20
million times and the best line has to
be
when rod ponton the lawyer feels the
need to clarify to the court
that he's not a cat that cap filter that
he was using
is one of several filters you can get on
zoom to liven up the experience
most people use it for calls with family
and friends probably not a work call
definitely uh not a court hearing but to
be fair to mr ponton it didn't it didn't
seem that he actually intended
to use that filter and he actually said
to the judge he was prepared to go
forward with the hearing as a cat the
judge thought it was best to resolve the
issue first
and sky news spoke to judge roy ferguson
this is a time when people are are down
and
depressed and lonely and angry
at each other and at the government and
this has been just
a small little glimpse unintentional as
it was by me
into what things need to be again
everyone is
enjoying it the feedback is all positive
people are happy to see it and they're
laughing
and i hear that that's something we need
more of
now many of us are used to awkward zoom
experiences by now but this video really
was
something else and hopefully there'll be
more of these kind of clips
to cheer us all up kate thanks very much
indeed
i mean what sort of dafty leaves the
filter on uh time now for the weather
here's nazney
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning a bitterly cold one once
again for today particularly so this
morning
temperatures dropped down to minus 17.1
degrees celsius across the
scottish highlands last night making it
the coldest night
of the year so far of the winter so far
and in 10 years and tonight is set to
be even colder temperatures could drop
close to -20 degrees celsius in rural
spots of scotland
but despite it being very cold in
scotland all areas are chilly this
morning temperatures below freezing for
most with a widespread severe frost
there are also plenty of snow
showers across eastern areas and those
brisk easterly winds although they will
be lighter than the last few days so not
so much of a wind chill out there for
today they will still continue to drag
in those
snow showers throughout today giving
further accumulations across
eastern parts of scotland and england
and perhaps even for eastern parts of
ireland but
generally across western areas it will
be mainly dry
and bright and there will be sunny
spells elsewhere as well but
still snow showers in the east
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nice thanks very much let's stick with
the weather shall we speak to skies emma
birchley who's joining us now
uh from ipswich um how's it looking this
morning no hat on which is surely a
positive sign
yeah i'm i'm very bold and strong it is
really cold though i have to say here a
really biting
wind still the snow arrived early hours
of sunday morning there's been more of
it on and off since then and it's
causing all sorts of disruption
and in scotland in the highlands the
snow has been drifting
causing some pretty amazing scenes and
some very difficult
driving conditions back in east anglia
where i am
here and because of the rural nature of
many of the roads which remain untreated
it's meant that
many clothes are have schools are having
to remain closed so
uh in norfolk 150 closures again today
there are a
couple of dozen here in suffolk also
closures in essex
and while most vaccination centers have
now reopened there are still
some closed an age uk is is has warned
um elderly people not to feel that they
absolutely have to go to their
appointments
even if their vaccination center is is
open they can reschedule don't go out
if it's dangerous because the
temperatures are due to stay cold
for days to come and it means the snow's
not likely to go anywhere fast
emma many thanks indeed uh well as usual
let's take a look
at the latest coronavirus figures that
we have
uh 12 364 new coronavirus cases have
been confirmed
for the 1052 people have died within 28
days of testing positive
covert 19 uh bringing the uk total to
113
850. so far well in fact we've got an
update to that it's around about 13.1
at first doses of a vaccine have been
administered
dr siddhartha data is who europe's
program manager
for vaccine preventable diseases and
immunization
and he joins us now on the programme
doctor gr great to have you
on this morning um i'm just wondering
from from your lofty vantage point what
you think
uh both of the the uk vaccine rollout
and indeed
the rollouts across the continent
yeah good morning thank you so much good
to join you today morning
so um first of all i think let me also
take a uh acknowledging the entire
effort made by the global community
for research and development of finding
a vaccine within
one year of detection of the virus so
this is an unprecedented and i think
the uh the sheer scale now would
focus on rolling out this vaccine i
think this is important that
everybody gets a vaccine the benefits of
the vaccine reaches everyone
fail and equitable and i think that is
extremely important
we we have really seen and learned
about the rollout of the vaccine in the
uk very impressive work being done
and i think the the issues that are the
challenges
that the country would face during the
rollout of the vaccine need to be
identified quickly and then the
challenge is addressed i think this will
happen in every country
because of the sheer scale of the kovite
19
vaccine rollout um dr data of course of
late there has been a renewed focus on
what's become known as vaccine
nationalism and of course
concerns about the developing world at
not getting access to the vaccines
as soon as they need it i mean that said
35
out of the 53 um countries in your
european region
have begun vaccinations i mean are are
we to be slightly concerned that even in
the industrialized west
we're not seeing the vaccine rollout
happening perhaps at the pace we would
like
yeah like you said uh you know 35 and
now it's 37 countries
in their who european region which have
rolled out
uh the covet 19 vaccination and
obviously
they the the lower middle income
countries and the lower income countries
of our region are falling behind
but i think they did this if you say
that whether we should be concerned the
answer is yes
the inequity in the vaccine roll out is
evident
but i think efforts are being made by
everyone in this whole process
and who gavi seppy
put out together this covax mechanism
which ensures
that everybody everywhere gets their
access to this vaccine
fair and equitable access to this global
public good
as we say is is paramount and then i
think
we have to ensure and make sure that we
do have mechanisms
that a country irrespective of its
income level
gets access to this vaccine and i think
you know
just keeping us safe will not keep
everybody safe i think everybody has to
save to keeps us safe
so and i think that is that that is we
when countries are making effort to keep
their populations protected
we also have to ensure that everybody
else is protected
so within that global public good access
to fair and equitably everywhere
is the mantra of of the covet 19 vaccine
rollout
dr siddhartha data great to have you on
the program this morning thanks very
much for your time thank you so much
well let's get more on the government's
new quarantine rules uh coming into
force for anyone traveling
to the uk from monday the shadow of home
secretary nick thomas simmons
joins us once again on the program and a
very good morning to you
um well let's start with the measures
that we heard announced
in the commons yesterday about matt
hancock i mean taken together
they certainly will do a considerable
amount
to beef up our protections at our
borders
well firstly good morning good to join
you but the
measures announced yesterday are too
limited
to limit hotel quarantine to the 33
so-called red list
countries isn't enough this is a
race against time the greatest threat
would be
a mutant strain of the virus that
arrived on these shores
that seriously threatened the efficacy
of our vaccine program the government
has to do
everything it possibly can to prevent
that from happening that's why i've
asked subject of course to exceptions to
a comprehensive system of human
quarantining for all arrivals that is
what is required
and yesterday's measures felt well short
of that
sure everyone however accepts the fact
and plenty of people accept the fact i
should say that we are going to be
living
with covet 19 for for years to come that
there will be covert 19 present
somewhere for for many years whilst it
continues to exist in existing numbers
variants mutations are always possible
so in your mind then at what point would
it be possible for us
to move away from restrictions on the
borders
well firstly what would happen if we
introduced
the comprehensive sum of hotel
quarantine
which we should do is we would actually
have
breathing space we would have breathing
space in terms of our
vaccine rollout first of all absolutely
critical
but also breathing space in terms of the
brilliant work that our scientists are
doing
the genomic sequencing mapping out
variants and indeed different possible
variants
that's why that is absolutely crucial
now
and later of course we're able to look
at the stage of the vaccine rollout for
the work our scientists have done
take that scientific advice as to when
the measure
could be eased hopefully at some point
of course no longer needed
at all but the urgency now is to get
this into place
it is a race against time the government
can't
order to be behind the curve again as
they live for example on formal
quarantine he wasn't even introduced
until last june
they were behind the curve on testing at
the bar only introduced recently
and i urge them again don't be under the
curve and only do this on a limited
basis now
in terms of the possibility of a prison
sentence
for someone who is at less than honest
or
out and out lies i mean what do you make
of the idea that someone could be
spending 10 years in clink
for lying on a farm look i do think
there needs to be
a significant penalty for lying on a
panzer locator form which clearly
is a very serious to do and has profound
consequences
but like you as you replied then in the
question i am
very concerned about the 10 year
suggestion for health secretary i would
want to see more details of that
he substitutes is he talking about some
sort of sliding scale for example of
last year's versions of the offenses
attracting a lower sense and secondly
crucially
how does that work with the existing
fraud and dishonesty offense that exists
and indeed
other serious violent and sexual
offences as well so clearly i would want
to look at the detail
crucially crucially what we can't do is
now
an announcement for an eye-catching
figure on a
to detract or distract away from what is
actually required here
which is that comprehensive hotel
foreign system
that needs to be introduced just on the
kind of the ideological underpinnings of
the government's public health strategy
do you perhaps feel
that the government have requested have
asked
have urged the public to do things on
too many occasions
rather than compelled them to do so with
the threat of criminal punishment if
they do not
no i think i think compulsion would
be counterproductive in a lot of cases
clearly
the rule of law clearly you have
guidelines do you have laws that have
been introduced that incidentally our
police frontline police have been you
know very bravely
ensuring that are enforced but let's not
forget
either that the british people have made
extraordinary sacrifices throughout this
pandemic the vast majority of the public
have been
observing the law observing the
guidelines observing the rule
and that is as well an argument why
the government should be doing more on
our borders now we cannot put the
sacrifices of the british people
remarkable sacrifices at risk the
government shouldn't
be doing that the u.s senate has voted
to continue with donald
trump's impeachment trial allowing the
full process to begin the former
president is charged with
inciting an insurrection for his role in
the deadly capitol hill riots at the
beginning of last month
our u.s correspondent cordelia lynch has
the detail
we've seen the somber walk before but
this
impeachment delivered what the last one
lacked
mr asking you're recognized an opening
gut punch
a chilling montage from the crime scene
itself
we fight like hell and if you don't
fight like hell you're not going to have
a country anymore
that's a high crime and misdemeanor if
that's not an
impeachable offense then there is no
such thing
for this sequel it wasn't a foggy phone
call to ukraine in dispute
but whether or not a president incited
an insurrection
the defense tried to put the brakes on
from the start
arguing congress shouldn't even be
trying the case
now donald trump is a private citizen
presidents are impeachable because
presidents are removable
former presidents are not because they
cannot be
removed on this vote the age of 56
the days are 44. they lost their
constitutional case in a vote
now they'll have to rely on defending mr
trump's words
before the siege and his right to say
them
on a day many members witnessed up close
it was surreal i mean i i'm used to
protests i'm used to freedom of speech
i'm used to people being angry and being
disruptive
i never realized how serious it was
you did not understand that until you
saw videos
the next day and days later but whatever
searing testimony there might be
here's the spoiler the senate will
almost certainly acquit
donald trump do you think ultimately
it's a good thing
that it's going ahead well i think it's
a good thing that we're
taking seriously the um very serious
events of january 6th
now the only president to have been
impeached twice whether he merits
conviction taking this
taking a look at this seriously i think
is worthy of the constitutional process
no one is expecting big concessions from
either side
but they do share one perspective
dragging this process out
could hurt them both cordelia lynch sky
news
washington
i'm pleased to say we're joined once
again on the programme by the former
democrat ohio state senator capri cafaro
and the republican strategist jennifer
kern ladies
wonderful to see you both this morning
thank you for coming on at such a late
hour for both of you um
capri to you first of course historic
second impeachment trial are we to
expect much more from it than an awful
lot of hot air
in the chamber you know sadly not
unfortunately this is something that
should not be political
uh but has uh just become increasingly
increasingly
more uh politicized and charged uh and
as your reporter said i mean it really
is negative
for both democrats and republicans
politically um
because it certainly doesn't help either
of them to to gain the confidence of the
american people
uh unfortunately the other part of this
is that uh
you know there is a lot to consider
um on the merits of the case uh we saw
today about the
the issues of the jurisdictional issues
and that are the constitutionality
of the uh impeachment impeachment that
occurred by the house and now
going into the trial of the senate and
and what we did see
pretty much was a vote along party lines
which signals
to the american people that this is a
show
trial that the that the senators um are
are really operating from a place where
they've already made their mind up
and that they're not looking at the
facts before them as they should now
now impeachment does not work like a
court of law
um and we certainly should not be
surprised that this is this is a uh
you know a show because it has been this
is you know it was
a year ago um but we are still facing
very serious
constitutional issues of insurrection
uh high crimes and misdemeanors and
whether or not
a president now a former president
should be held accountable
and when you have this polarized vote
it shows the american people frankly at
least in my view that neither side is
being serious about
hearing the evidence before them they
just want to do what they think is
politically expedient
jennifer i'm sure there's much in that
that you would agree with i noticed you
nodding on but i suppose the one thing
that the second impeachment trial does
is it forces republicans on capitol hill
to to state their position to make it
absolutely clear whether or not they
support donald trump or whether they
don't
yeah it is an interesting test i think
by democrats and by the way i think we
need more democrats like
capri cafaro uh the world would be a
much better place
um and we wouldn't be having this
conversation um look
i think there's no doubt that there were
aids and and
and allies around president trump who
who led to the
insurrection uh on january 6. uh people
that are used to throwing bombs like
this the proverbial bombs of course but
people like steve bannon's of the world
and the roger stones of the world i
think they really goaded him
into sort of whipping people into a
frenzy but i don't think that it rose to
the level of an incitement of a right
i've listened to the tape
multiple times probably more than anyone
has just looking for some shred of
evidence of that but but here's what it
really comes down to capri is right
this is really a dog and pony show this
is a big charade
it will end in an acquittal because
there is no way that
17 republican senators are going to go
up on a yes vote for a conviction and
they were lucky to even have one extra
republican today
uh vote on the constitutionality issue
so you only had six republicans go up
today
so by and large this is going to end
with a little bit of a fizzle
it's not going to end in a conviction
and then maybe we can move on to helping
the american people of both parties you
know millions of people still out of
work
we're still trying to get past kova 19.
that would be helpful
capri then a word a word from you do you
think joe biden would prefer for this
not this process not to go forward then
now as i understand it he
has announced that he will not be
sitting watching at the impeachment
travel
why would he he's the president of the
united states he's probably got a few
other things to be getting on with but
would he prefer this not to happen
well i think he signaled uh even from
from the start when
when the impeachment rumblings were
boiling up
after the uh activity of january 6 that
he was going to leave this to congress
to decide uh which is signaling the fact
that he did not want to weigh in on this
issue i think that what he's trying to
do is present himself as someone who is
looking towards governing the nation on
the backdrop of a
you know dual pandemic of a crisis uh in
in public health as well as you know a
an economic crisis to a certain extent
as well
due to the covet 19 pandemic and so you
know certainly it's a bit of a
distraction coming into his first
days of of his term where he has so much
that he has to do
including this very significant covet
relief package that has been pending
so i'm sure it's not preferable but i
would also say that there are a lot of
democrats and a lot of americans for
that matter
that do feel that uh president trump um
should be held accountable or at least
we should go through this process
to show that uh presidents of the united
states in the
last days uh sitting in the white house
cannot just
uh do whatever they want um and
not have anyone at least try to take
action so not necessarily saying that he
should be convicted but i think there
are a lot of people particularly on the
democratic side
saying that we need to go through this
process it's important for the integrity
of of our institutions and democracy and
then for that reason
i think joe biden has no choice but
his democrats want to have it i just i
just i just want to give jennifer
one last chance to respond because i
think we found the point of divergence
between the two i got to see her face
whilst you were talking there
well one area we disagree on joe biden
it holds the white house he is the de
facto leader of the democrat party
he gave a speech on his inauguration day
saying we should all unite it should be
about unity
he could stop this impeachment charade
with one statement
and that's a phone call to nancy pelosi
and chuck schumer to say
stand down on this silly impeachment
thing let's all truly unite let's get
past kova 19 together
let's leave the past where it needs to
be which is in the past
he hasn't done that and that shows you
joe biden maybe doesn't mean that he
really wants unity
or maybe it shows joe biden's really not
in charge nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
are in charge
of the democrat party we will see i'm
afraid guys jennifer
uh capri i'm so sorry but we are we are
entirely out of time
thank you for joining us and thank you
for both being the happiest smiliest
guest
and i've ever had on this program in the
wee hours the morning as well
thanks for joining us guys we'll speak
again soon
time for us to see how the weather is
looking today
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning we continue with a very
cold weather for
most places for the rest of this week
and the risk of
ice frosts and snow showers as well
in fact this morning is a very cold
start across parts of scottish highlands
temperatures dropped down to minus 17.1
degrees celsius making the coldest night
of the year so far
the coldest night of this winter and
this coldest night since december 2010
and tonight could be even colder
temperatures are forecast there to get
close to minus 20 degrees celsius
there's a severe frost for most places
out there this morning as well also lots
of snow showers currently across the
eastern parts of britain in particular
some of them
are merging into longer spells of snow
particularly across central and eastern
parts of scotland and northeast england
down towards parts
of kent as well so further accumulations
of snow likely across these parts
some snow flurries may push further west
but it does look like for western areas
of the uk as well as for ireland and
northern ireland
it will be mainly dry and bright but for
all areas cold today although winds
lighter than recently
the weather sponsored by qatar airways